I remember being a little kid lying in bed at night and just looking out at the moon in whatever phase it was in.
I was thinking, man, my friends that live like 20 miles away, they can probably look out and see that same exact moon.
And then when I was in the Navy and I would look out at the Moon and I'd be halfway around the planet,
I would think, man, My brother can see that Moon where he is, and he's halfway around the Planet from where I am.
And it's a connection of life on Earth. We can all look up and see that Moon.
It represents history. It is a witness plate. Everything that's ever happened to the moon is still written on the moon. There's no processes of wind or change in the earth, geologic processes like we have here that change it. And something that's been telling and can read out the story of its own evolution, there's something beautiful about that.
I've also learned from my indigenous mentors that they refer to the moon as Grandmother
Moon.
So you've probably heard of Mother Earth, they use Grandmother Moon because Grandmother
Moon is responsible for the water in their community.
The grandmothers, you know, sort of protect the water source, just like the moon moves
the water around the planet, affects the tides.
It's something that represents something different for each individual culture around the planet.
And that's really neat because we all share that same moon in the night sky.
We all have seen the same side of the moon in different lighting conditions our whole
lives.
And so it seems very familiar to us, but it's also kind of unknown.
When we get up close, some of the imagery that we'll get to describe and to share with
people will be very unique.
And that nature, both of those things being true about this one entity that we all know
just is really special.
just the epitome of a symbol of both something that's in each of our hearts
but this also represents exploration and reaching. You're looking at a live view
inside Artemis Mission Control here at Johnson Space Center in Houston, Texas. We
are currently out of contact with the Artemis 2 crew. This was a planned or
not really a planned but a tracked loss of signal that occurs when the crew
flies behind the moon we use the deep space network to communicate with the
crew and when they are behind the moon they are out of reach of that deep space
network and when you consider our non-stop communications during the time
in which we live this is even more striking for the Artemis 2 crew they're
only currently communicating with each other now we expect to regain those
communications in under nine minutes from now and we also are hopeful for a
view of Earthrise. Despite being out of communication, the crew is continuously capturing imagery
of their predetermined lunar targets.
Now about seven minutes, 25 seconds until we anticipate regaining communications with
the Artemis II crew aboard Orion. In the meantime, Artemis II Lunar Science Deputy Lead Marie
Henderson has trained these astronauts to capture and document their views of the lunar
surface for all of us to enjoy back here on Earth.
I cannot wait to hear their voices when they get to the far side of the moon and I can
hear them talk about seeing the moon out their window.
I try to imagine it now and just like tear up thinking about it.
Oh now I gotta hold on a second.
We have human eyeballs connected to wonderfully smart brains our astronaut friends have.
They are going to be able to observe the moon in multiple different ways.
They can use their eyes.
They'll look through their camera and snap pictures and just looking out the window, getting that human experience.
But during Apollo, the astronauts were so much closer to the lunar surface.
Our astronauts are going to be doing a flyby at a higher altitude.
So they're going to be able to see the whole moon as a lunar disk on the lunar far side.
That's a brand new, unique perspective that humans haven't been able to look at before.
We are doing a lot of lunar geography training with them.
They have study sessions and quizzes they can do that are assigned to them.
You know, even if you're an astronaut, you still get homework.
We actually get in the mock-up.
In that enclosed physical space, we have to think through the hardware that they have,
the cameras, the computers, their microphones to make these observations.
There's four windows up front.
Through one of those windows, one of our astronauts will be using a Nikon D5 camera
with an 80 to 400 millimeter lens.
So something that allows them to zoom in really far
and actually take more detailed observations of the surface.
It's almost like looking through a pair of binoculars as well.
It's just like being a geologist out in the field.
They're going, they're telling us what they're seeing,
looking for colors, textures, different morphologies,
and comparing the region that we're having them look at
to the regions that are around them.
We have a science team that is planning the targets
that are going to be observed,
putting them all on the timeline
how they're going to be observed and then taking the first look at the data when it comes down
the apollo astronauts were only on the moon for 300 hours total and they only went to the equator
that's like going to places that were safer landing sites and they only saw so little 300
hours total and so we have so much more to explore and so much more
to learn and we are the beginning of the next generation that gets to start
being a part of these discoveries.
We are now 4 minutes and 28 seconds until we expect to regain communications with the
astronauts flying aboard Orion on the Artemis II mission.
They are now flying behind the moon.
While behind the moon at an MET, or mission elapsed time, of 5 days, 25 minutes and 34
seconds, we expect this was the point in which they made their closest approach, 4,067 statute
miles above the lunar surface.
We're live in the Artemis Mission Control Room in Houston,
but we are not the only room monitoring today's flyby.
As you can see, this is the SUR, the Science Evaluation Room.
It's in the same building and just down the hall.
It's a multidisciplinary science team supporting the Artemis II crew in real time,
including experts in lunar geology, impact cratering, volcanism,
polar science, imaging, and visualization.
You can see the SUR here.
That's the Science Evaluation Room.
It's embedded within mission control to provide science input during live operations like what we see today.
But additionally, the science mission operations room is a back room that processes data, evaluates imagery, and supports rapid analysis.
We also have our science officer, Kelsey Young, here on console today.
She's serving as the primary interface between the science team and the flight controllers, ensuring science priorities are represented during mission execution.
coming up on 1 minute and 36 seconds until we contact Orion. Meanwhile aboard the spacecraft,
the crew has continued executing their lunar flyby tasks. As we discussed earlier today,
these activities have been precisely timelined and this is the fourth of five blocks of time
during which the crew will be observing the moon from Orion's windows. At this time,
pilot Victor Glover and mission specialist Christina Cook are observing
the moon at windows 2 and 3. One crew member is in window 2 with a blue shroud
over the window taking photos and using an 80 to 400 millimeter zoom lens while
the other astronaut is in window 3 using their portable computing device also
known as a PCD to make annotations and both of those crew members are making
audio recordings of what they are seeing.
They are wearing headsets connected to their PCDs and those audio recordings are being
sent to the science team tonight.
We are not hearing those live, however we have been hearing quite a lot of great descriptions
from the crew who have been serving as the support.
Right now the support team members are Reed Wiseman and Jeremy Hansen.
Those team members are providing science sit reps, situation reports, calling down a few
times each hour to discuss what they're observing and even though we're out of
contact with them right now they are still conducting those science sit reps
as they'll be available once they come back around the moon. The situation
reports include how the crew is positioned, any missed targets or
anything unexpected they saw. They're also including lunar target descriptions,
any hardware issues, and their emotions and reactions. Again we are standing by
to acquire signal from the Orion spacecraft. We're in the Artemis Mission
control room at Johnson Space Center getting our preliminary contact with
Orion that acquisition of signal coming after a 40 minute loss of signal during
which the crew was flying behind the moon out of contact with anyone on Earth.
We are getting our first views from Orion after the loss of signal. Orion has
come back around the other side of the moon and that little crescent that you
see is earth over 252 000 miles away with this transit complete lunar flyby continues but orion
has also technically begun its journey home right now the crew are getting a few moments to enjoy
and take photos of earthrise for themselves and we expect to contact them shortly but we do have
good signal coming from orion this view from inside the orion spacecraft all four astronauts
now back on the other side of the moon and in contact with us on Earth.
Their tasks for lunar flyby did not stop as they went behind the moon and out of contact
with us.
We anticipate during that time they were attempting to image some impact flashes, short-lived
flashes on the lunar surface, which would be caused by impact bombardment and potentially
even alofted lunar dust.
Right now, of course, they are getting pictures of Earthrise.
this target they will get a short observation break it's about an hour long actually
integrity integrity we have you loud and clear tummy earth again to asia africa and oceania
we are looking back at you we hear you can look up and see the moon right now
we see you too when we burn i said that we do not leave earth explore we will build we will build
ships we will visit again we will construct we will drive rovers we will do radio astronomy
we will found we will inspire but ultimately we will always choose earth we will always
choose each other integrity from earth our single system fragile and interconnected we copy
those of us that can are looking back those first communications back with the astronauts aboard
Orion, Christina Cook calling back to what she said just before a translunar injection burn,
that with this burn, we do not leave Earth, we choose it. The translunar
injection burn served as not only what put them on this trajectory to fly around the Moon,
but what also committed them to splashing down in the Pacific Ocean on flight day 10.
At this time, the crew is entering an observation break. We expect this to last about an hour,
And it's probably a welcomed break following their very, very busy day taking pictures,
making annotations, making audio recordings, and communicating all of the wonderful things
that they are seeing on the moon.
This observation break is also partially due to the fact that we will be entering an eclipse
later.
This will be the first solar eclipse that humans have seen from the moon.
The astronauts will need to wear eclipse glasses for the first two minutes until the sun is
completely covered by the moon, and then they have additional targets that the science team
is hoping that they will photograph.
We will have communications with them during that eclipse time frame.
Because of that eclipse, Orion's attitude must be changed right now so that its solar
arrays are in the sun.
This will help it charge the batteries needed to power it through that eclipse time-frame.
This view on your screen is a visualization.
The spacecraft is now 4,224 miles away from the Moon and that number will now continue
to grow while the number of distance from Earth, 252,699 miles, will continue to shrink
all the way until our crew is back home.
Again, we are MET, Mission Elapsed Time, five days and 58 minutes since the launch of Artemis
2.
We have reestablished communications with the crew and the Orion spacecraft now entering
a little bit of a break while they are out of visibility or the moon is out of their
visibility.
The spacecraft will be reoriented to view the moon ahead of an upcoming eclipse.
This current attitude maneuver helps charge the solar arrays and batteries aboard Orion
that will power them through the eclipse.
Integrity, Houston, in mission control, all of your flight controllers and your flight director have flipped their Artemis II patches around.
We are earthbound and ready to bring you home.
A very special moment just now in mission control.
Ahead of the crew's flight to Kennedy Space Center and during one of their last sims or simulations here,
they visited the mission control team in Artemis Mission Control in Houston and brought us each a patch.
Everyone in the flight control room has had these on their signifiers at their console.
On one side of the patch that you've probably seen is the moon with the Earth behind it.
Now that we've passed behind the moon and we are returning home,
the flight control team has instructed everyone in the room to switch their patch around
so that the Earth is closer and the moon is behind us.
We are really looking forward to seeing the Artemis II crew
And the CAPCOM Jenny Gibbons did call that update up to the crew
that the flight control team here has turned their patches around,
as was instructed by the crew during that last sim.
And we are counting down the days until they get home.
They are now five days, one hour and three minutes mission elapsed time
into the Artemis II mission.
Joining me here in the room, Artemis Mission Control,
I have Angela Garcia, Artemis II science officer.
Thanks for being here, Angela.
It is an honor to be here.
What a day.
Everyone's been buzzing.
I can't contain myself.
So it's been a really awesome day.
So you're sitting on console at the Science Console now.
Have you been in the CIR earlier today?
There's a lot going on.
So I went here first, then I'm going to go there after.
All right, Integrity, we hear you.
That was a little clipped, but I think we have a better link now.
We experienced some blockage from a solar array.
We moved it and we are in bias, tail to sun.
Affirm and integrity, just so you know, we did not hear your response once we flipped our patches.
Jeremy, we heard you call down but you were eclipsed and then we briefly lost comm.
Clapper back.
Mission control flipped your patches around and that that side of the patch is getting
to see the light of day.
Thanks for sharing that with us.
Our pleasure.
Okay, Angela, so can you tell me a little bit about your role supporting Artemis II
and the science preparation for the mission?
Yes. So I'm one of the three science officers. So Kelsey's been on console all day. I'll take over
kind of closer to the end of the day. And then Trevor Graff is on the planning shift. And so
it's the three of us in this 24-hour cycle supporting the mission. And so the science
officer console is a brand new console to mission control. And it's not every day that you get
a new discipline incorporated into mission control. So it's been such a significant
milestone for us and it's just a testament to like the commitment that
the flight operations directorate and NASA have that they're gonna be
integrating science and maximizing science throughout Artemis so it's it's
really exciting and then the science preparation yeah so I'm on the
operations team but I'm also on the training team so all the incredible
training and shout outs that you've gotten today just it warms warms my
heart and forms everybody's heart in the science evaluation worm I I promise you
that but see all the classroom training the field training the mission simulations right we were
part of all of it and you know that is what we did to get the crew to be they are a part of the
science team and they are the the forefront that like that nice edge and they're just been doing
such a great job today i know i imagine that you have to be pretty proud of them their reports have
been fantastic so i would like to know a little bit about how you have developed procedures for
this crew. What kind of science activities are they carrying out inside the spacecraft?
Yeah, so the procedure development has been a unique challenge. I would say the exploration
science that we're doing is inherently pretty flexible and operations is I'd say inherently
has more structure and rigidity and so to marry the two and to operationalize the science that
we want to get done has has been a challenge. But it's I think we've been able to to go through
these processes and create good products at the end and have a good plan and yeah
it's been it's it's it really great what was the second part
of your question just what kind of these these science activities that they're
performing which of those have you really had a hand in yeah so a lot of
the the procedures help organize what the crew is doing in the cabin and I
know we've talked a lot about you know what they've been doing and they've been
doing a lot and it's been a little dark so I can re-explain what some of those
things that they're doing.
So the observation blocks are about an hour long, and the crew is organized, the four
crew members are organized into two pairs of two, the window team and the cabin team.
And the lunar targeting package that you've been showing up and what we've, that the crew
have on their handheld tablets is really the instructions for the window team.
So the window team, the two crew members are looking out the window.
One has the camera with the long lens.
has, they're just looking out the window with their unaided eye, and they're taking these
detailed observations. And then halfway in that observation block, they do those, the window team
position swap. So that's what you've been, what Capcom's been calling out, and they'll switch
positions. So each crew member has a chance to have that long lens. And then that's just what
the window team is doing. There's also the cabin team, where they also have duties that they're
doing. We're asking a lot of the crew in this time. And then the cabin team they're taking,
they have the interior camera and they're taking images inside the cabin they're also supporting
the window team where you know you've heard some call outs where looking out at the bright moon
and then looking inside the dark cabin and looking at their led screen is is a lot so the cabin team
is also helping support a target and guide the window team into specific into specific targets
on their plan they're also helping call out these science situational reps so they're looking out at
a different window and listening in to what the crew
who are really down and in in the science
on the window team are doing and they're giving us insight.
And those recordings that the window team is doing
are gonna be uplinked or downlinked overnight
and we're gonna be able to chew on that data.
But yeah, they're helping, they're doing a lot.
And so making sure we have a plan that's flexible
but also make sure that we check off all those boxes
was really important.
So tell me a little bit more,
you talked earlier about the analogs
that the crew has done.
What kind of analogs or environments
were really useful for this?
Yeah, so for procedure development, right,
you have so many different environments that you can do.
As you have classroom, you, like we said,
we have, you have the Orion mockup, you have simulations,
and for at least for developing the plan,
we kind of did it in a tiered approach
because each of those different analog environments
helps us answer a slightly different question
and has a little bit of a higher fidelity.
So we would start with the classroom.
So we would get, you know, we would just get into a classroom.
We would put all the hardware on the table, and then we'd almost role play of, like, you be Victor, you be Reed, you be Jeremy, and I'll be Christina.
And, like, let's just do the plan how we think we should do it, write that down, and then just keep iterating on that.
And then Integrity Houston for a tag-up pre-ForwardLink LOS in place of the flight director conference.
All right, crew, I'm going to roll through a couple of topics here.
the first two are for timeline. First of all, read for your toilet maintenance. It is a shortened
toilet maintenance where you do not have to do the aux zone change out. That portion of the
procedure is cancelled. Victor, you have an HHP stop activity on your timeline. We need you to
perform that as scheduled for bandwidth reasons. For your next portion of the flyby, in particular
the eclipse we want to remind you that you can take off the eclipse glasses when the sun sets
and you are simply looking at the corona and then finally for the d5 with the long or zoom lens
which is set for solar corona we want to
remind you that when you are capturing earth shine you will likely have to adjust the exposure
that's all i have for you let me know if you have anything for us
All right, just a quick call up to the crew ahead of a forward link LOS,
meaning that we won't be communicating with them,
but we will be receiving their communications and data during that time frame.
So Angela, we were talking about analog environments.
You were telling me about the classroom and getting in there
and pretending who's Victor, who's Reed.
Tell me more about this.
Yeah, it works pretty well.
So you're going to do the plan how you expect it to be, and then, you know,
once we finalize that plan, we'll give it to a completely new group of people
and have them practice it, and then they'll be like,
these steps don't make sense,
and we'll reiterate on it over and over.
Then we'll take it to a higher fidelity environment
like the Orion mockup, and we'll do the same thing
because that volume is smaller, the window placement,
their seating, what things have we forgotten
with this addition of this environment?
And then once we reiterate on that,
we'll take then, we'll give it to the crew
and have them execute off of it during mission simulations.
That's the highest fidelity that we can do
before we send it to space.
So we've, this is the first time we've had to do this
because we're a brand new console.
And I'm just, it just sparks so many neurons of like,
how are we gonna do this for surface missions
and integrate this in so many different ways?
So excited to have kicked off this process,
but there's so much more to come.
Fascinating.
And I think it was really well thought out too,
because each crew member gets an opportunity
to do each task.
And so you're getting different perspectives
and different insights from each crew member,
maybe even about the same target,
but something that one person sees could be completely different than something another
person notices. So we also know that Artemis 2 has traveled, they're now on their way home,
but they traveled farther from the moon than the Apollo missions did. So what makes
that vantage point scientifically interesting? Yeah, observations are so fundamental in the
scientific toolkit, particularly observations from different perspectives, different scales,
and with different techniques and so for this so we really tried to make the plan
to optimize those there's pros and cons for for all those things for this
mission so we really just focus the plan to have all those pros so in terms of
scale this zoomed out scale you can learn different things this zoomed are
this different perspective so their perspective as Kelsey talked about
photometry around when they orbit the moon and then also just they're
different, the different things they're able to observe. So yeah, let me let me talk a little bit
about scale, because I think observations at different scales, you can you can gain a lot of
different information. So like, for example, if you're an astronaut on the surface looking at a
rock, and you describe at this micro scale, so in training, we kind of talk about observations from
micro to macro, or from outcrop to orbit. So looking at, you know, a rock at this scale,
You can describe its components.
You can describe what it's made of and its colors
and its minerals, and you're like, okay,
and this rock came from this boulder, and it's this part
of this boulder.
And these are the different things that I'm observing
around, it gives me context to this sample.
And then you zoom out a little bit more, and you like, okay.
Well, I can see that this boulder came from, you know,
it rolled from this mountain ridge or this high ridge feature.
And then because I can see the trail that it came from, okay,
now let me describe this ridge and, you know, different parts in it and maybe other boulders
that I'm seeing. And then you zoom out further of the orbit scale. And you're like, this ridge
is a part of this larger crater. So all of those different steps give you different information.
And so that's why observations at these different scales and these different perspectives are so
important. So this zoomed out kind of far view is this full lunar disk view. It's the full lunar,
you know, on Earth, we see the full lunar disk as well. But now we're able to see it on the far
side and we're able to see it, you know, all at the same time, which enables the astronauts
to compare very quickly to different parts of the surface.
And the color particularly is very compelling because you can just be able to very quickly
compare from, you know three different regions, is it in the same family, is this actually
a little bit different, you know compare that to what they see in their orbital data that
that they have access to on their portable computers
and really just be able to tease out
that nuance and information.
Yeah, we heard them make a lot of those connections today
and especially the color.
We talked with Kelsey about this a little bit,
just how exciting it was to hear the browns and greens
and things like that.
I cannot wait to see those pictures.
So one last question, we are coming up
on the last lunar flyby observation block
and this is when we are going into a solar eclipse.
So can you tell me what you're interested
and the crew learning during that timeframe?
Yeah, so the dataset, yes, there's so many things,
how to pick one.
So I'd say the thing that I'm most interested in seeing
is some of their annotations that they're taking.
So in this opportunity,
it's a very dynamic type of experience
in that we don't normally see this activity.
And so being able to have crew observe the solar corona
and then also annotate it on their portable computing device
is just such a unique thing that humans can give to missions
and also particularly being able to annotate
what they're observing while they're talking about it
is also unique to being able to have astronauts
in orbit as well,
because we won't be able to have annotations
on the lunar surface
because the astronauts will be in suits,
they're gonna be collecting samples,
to be deploying instruments and so personally i'm really excited to see some of these annotations
and to see how that develops over time because it's you've heard a lot of descriptions and i
think you know when people are describing something that's unique and different
you can interpret it differently but if you're drawing and you're marking particularly just
going back to like the color provinces for example and those boundaries you know exactly what they
meant and really I just I'm just very excited about those annotations there's been some famous
annotations that the Apollo crew have made particularly about solar coronas and the
structures that have and lofted dust that have given a lot of you know debate within the
scientific community of they're observing this phenomenon and now it's our job to hypothesize
of like why are they observing this like what is what is going on so I think that's just a really
cool part of exploration and science and you know this this beautiful thing that we're about to do
well now you've got me excited about the annotations too i mean i've been excited
about the pictures and the audio but now don't sleep on the annotations i am very excited to see
these little sketches that they're able to draw out and we have pictures that they can just draw
right on it's like this particular thing is different than what we've seen so i'm excited
about that i'm excited too angela garcia thank you so much for joining us today and have a great time
tonight on console thank you and you've been doing a great job and it's so excited to see where we
go from here thank you so much integrity houston you have three minutes until we go into a forward
link los we will be back up with you in about an hour during the eclipse on madrid likewise
we're live in artemis mission control ajonton space center in houston texas this alive view
from the Orion spacecraft with our Artemis II crew inside.
That's Reid Wiseman, Victor Glover, Christina Cook, and Jeremy Hansen.
We are still live for our lunar flyby coverage. The crew is in a short break while the spacecraft
is pivoted away from the Moon. We are going to be going into a solar eclipse.
This is the first time anyone has ever seen a solar eclipse from the Moon,
so it's going to be a unique vantage point for our crew but ahead of heading into that solar eclipse
we need to charge the batteries on the orion spacecraft therefore we have positioned the
solar arrays into the sunlight to allow time for those batteries to charge we will get back
pointed at the moon just in time for that solar eclipse we are also in a forward link
los what that means is essentially we cannot send calls or commands to the crew right now
from the ground however we clearly get all of their data and communications the spacecraft is
now 4 632 miles away from the moon and that number will only continue to grow as the distance from
earth shrinks now 252 523 miles away our closest approach to the moon today was approximately 4067
statute miles in altitude our maximum distance from the earth is suspected to be 252 756 statute
miles both of those moments came while orion was flying in their loss of signal time frame behind
the moon the crew also set that new record today beating the apollo 13 record of distance from
earth this is an animation or a visualization that you can track anytime day or night by visiting
NASA.gov slash track Artemis.
This shows you how the spacecraft is positioned as well
as their distance and velocity.
Now traveling 930 miles per hour.
During this break in their time today, the crew is working
on a couple of other tasks.
Some of those include their National Geographic
Timeline Test.
National Geographic was selected through a competitive process
by NASA to help tell the story of Artemis II.
So you've seen the crew with some GoPros inside the cabin,
taking videos and pictures and with other cameras as well.
National Geographic plans to leverage its portfolio
of media assets, including magazines,
social and digital content, and television programming
for engagement opportunities.
Throughout the flight, the crew has been
timelined a little bit each day to film from a shot list
provided by National Geographic,
and that includes their morning routine,
talking with their families, exercising,
and just their overall thoughts about the mission.
And I cannot wait to see that footage.
teams on the ground reporting that the spacecraft is looking good and that the power aboard
is good as well all setting us up in a proper position before eclipse the crew is in a little
break during our flyby coverage for today they will resume their flyby momentarily in about 30
minutes once they get into their observations during that solar eclipse now the moon is our
nearest celestial neighbor orbiting earth at less than a quarter of a million miles on average
When our astronauts venture there for future Artemis missions,
they'll target landing sites near the lunar South Pole.
There, ancient rocks, minerals and trapped water ice will not only provide resources
for human explorers, but they may also contain clues to the formation and evolution of our
planet and the solar system. Let's learn more about the lunar South
Pole with this video featuring Dr. Kelsey Young, Artemis Science Flight Operations Lead.
We learned a lot from the Apollo samples, but we still have a lot
left to learn about the moon, the Apollo missions visited only a pretty narrow swath of the moon.
All the missions were concentrated near the near side equator. Really interesting and really
critical insights were unlocked with the Apollo samples, but we have so many questions still to
answer about the moon and the evolution of the moon and liftoff of Artemis one. We rise together
back to the moon and beyond. NASA's Artemis missions are NASA's plan to send people to the
surface of the Moon. We'll be sending people and roving assets and scientific equipment to,
among other things, answer a lot of really compelling science questions.
Scientists have a lot to learn about the Moon. It's our nearest celestial neighbor here to Earth,
so what the Moon has experienced, we've experienced. Except here on Earth,
we have things like plate tectonics, oceans, forests, people that erase the rock record.
Whereas on the Moon, that whole record of our planet's history, of the Moon's history,
is just kind of waiting there at the surface for us to explore. The South Pole, which is where
Artemis missions are going to target, is specifically interesting for a couple key reasons.
We think there are volatiles at the South Pole of the Moon that are not present near the equator.
Things like water and water ice that are trapped in the lunar regolith, which basically just means
lunar soil, that can easily become untrapped from that lunar regolith and scientists can scoop up
and study for return to Earth. The lunar South Pole is a really exciting scientific target and
And it also comes with some challenges for operating.
For example, the lighting environment
will change drastically within the course of one mission
and even over, sometimes, the course of spacewalk.
So preparing the crew members,
preparing the hardware that we're sending to the moon,
and preparing the mission control teams
is really, really important.
The South Pole Aiken Basin is particularly exciting.
We think it's one of the oldest and largest
impact basins in the solar system.
And if we can get the right rock
from the South Pole Aichen Basin
and bring it back to our labs here on Earth,
we can use that sample to constrain the entire evolution
of our solar system and really understand the timing
of how the moon and our planet
and the entire solar system evolved.
You're looking at a live view aboard the Orion spacecraft
of the Artemis II crew,
working in the middle of one of their breaks,
or really their only break today
during this lunar flyby period.
Coming up next will be that solar eclipse.
Throughout the Artemis II mission, and of course throughout today,
you've likely heard the crew being called with the name Integrity.
The Artemis II crew members named their Orion spacecraft Integrity
during a news conference September 24, 2025.
The name Integrity embodies the foundation of trust, respect, candor, and humility across the crew
and the many engineers, technicians, scientists, planners,
and dreamers required for mission success.
They said this name is also a nod to the extensive integrated effort from the more than 300,000
spacecraft components to the thousands of people across the world that must come together
to venture to the moon and back, inspire the world, and set the course for a long-term
presence at the moon.
The crew also said the integrity is rooted in a shared core value of NASA, the agency's
astronaut office, and the CSA, the Canadian Space Agency.
We are five days, one hour and 38 minutes mission elapsed time into Artemis II.
In this view on the screen you can see the crew starting to even look through some photos
that they may have captured today.
We really look forward to sharing these photos with you as soon as we possibly can.
The best way to keep up with those is to follow NASA on social media.
You can do so at NASA and for this mission specifically at NASA Artemis.
We are in a forward link LOS or forward link loss of signal with the crew,
meaning that we're not able to communicate or send any commands to them right now as they were.
This is a tracked event that occurs at times,
but they could still provide communications down here to us
and we are obviously still receiving their video and their data.
This is Artemis Mission Control.
You heard Reid Wiseman, commander of the Artemis II mission aboard Orion make a call in the blind.
This means he knows we cannot call back and that he knows we may not receive his call.
However, we have good communications with the spacecraft.
They just cannot hear from us right now due to a forward link loss of signal.
Again, we were tracking that this would occur and we will regain that momentarily.
But that call that came down from Wiseman mentioned some imagery,
so we are very much looking forward to getting pictures taken from the moon today.
Again, to see those images make sure you follow NASA on our social media
at NASA and at NASA Artemis.
The view on your screen right now is an animation.
This is called Aero or Artemis Real Time Orbit website.
You can visit this for yourself at nasa.gov slash track Artemis and you can watch
as we continue to grow closer to Earth and farther away from the moon.
It's all seemed to happen so fast so far and we're coming up on splashdown
now in three days 23 minutes and 30 23 hours and 31 minutes this is artemis mission control we are
in a forward link los with the spacecraft we're not able to send commands or communications to
them right now however they could send them to us and we do get spacecraft data this is tracked as
we are on the deep space network this is the network that we use to communicate with the
spacecraft now that we are so far from Earth, over 252,000 miles.
We are still in our lunar flyby coverage.
The crew still have a very important and very exciting flyby milestone coming up when they
will see a solar eclipse from the moon, the first humans to ever do so.
Something that we also have to consider when it comes to our missions and launches is space
weather.
So since the Apollo 16 and 17 missions, there were some solar eruptions near that time frame
that could have been dangerous to our explorers.
Over those 50 years since those storms, the data, technology, and resources available
to NASA have improved, enabling advancements towards space weather forecasts and astronaut
protection, which is key to NASA's Artemis program to return astronauts to the moon.
Across our planet, billions of people depend on the invisible networks that connect us
to space.
Every day, those networks are at the mercy of our temperamental sun and the space weather
that it unleashes across our solar system.
That's why NASA's Space Weather Program tracks solar storms from the moment they erupt, modeling
their paths, anticipating their impacts, and leading the research that the world's industries
rely on.
NASA's space weather research and modeling is driven by the needs of society and enables
critical decision-making that equips pilots to reroute around high-radiation areas, farmers
to adjust GPS-based precision planting and harvesting plans, and power grid operators
to mitigate the impacts of potential surges.
For those exploring other worlds, NASA provides 24-7 space weather monitoring
for Artemis crews at the moon and future Mars astronauts
who may be exposed to dangerous levels of radiation during solar storms.
Whether you're a pilot or a passenger, a farmer or a consumer,
a power grid operator or energy customer, a satellite controller or GPS user,
space weather impacts us all.
this is a live view from the Orion spacecraft on the Artemis 2 mission it's
now been five days one hour and 54 minutes since we launched we are still
in our flyby coverage and the crew is on a short break right now as we have
changed the attitude of the spacecraft to help charge the batteries aboard we
use the solar arrays to gather energy from the Sun and store it in the
batteries that way when we are not in the sunlight we have those batteries to
continue powering Orion. Now we're doing so because the Artemis astronauts are
about to experience a solar eclipse from their capsule and this is a solar eclipse
that no one else on Earth will experience. This eclipse is about 54
minutes and to the astronauts it'll look a lot like a total solar eclipse on
Earth except the moon is going to be huge compared to the Sun unlike when you
watch one on Earth and the moon and the Sun appear about the same size in the
sky. We're interested to learn if they see the outer corona when the Sun is
fully obscured by the moon and because of how big the moon will be from their
perspective the total phase of the eclipse will last nearly an hour. The
astronauts will see a partial solar eclipse as the moon covers and uncovers
the Sun which is before and after totality so much like us on Earth they
will have eclipse glasses so they can safely view that portion. The astronauts
also be using cameras to capture images of the corona during the eclipse there also may be some
other planets visible during the eclipse including venus saturn mars and mercury if they can identify
what part of the sky they're looking at this can help train future artemis astronauts on what part
of the sky their seeing this provides useful knowledge in challenging situations when they
may need to rely on that information instead of instruments for navigation and orientation
Confirmation from teams here in the ground that we have reached the eclipse attitude meaning Orion is in the proper position to observe it.
The astronauts break during this observation period is now over and we are resuming their lunar flyby observations.
The first of these is sunset. This is the solar corona that we'll be looking for. It's the outer atmosphere of the sun.
The science team is also interested in if the astronauts can see polar plumes.
These are thin streamers that project from the sun's north and south poles.
Additionally, they're interested in seeing if the crew can witness coronal loops.
These are arcs close to the sun's surface.
And something else that we've previously mentioned is lunar dust.
This is dust from the moon that is lofted above the lunar surface and illuminated by
the sun.
was reported visible by Apollo astronauts. You're getting a live look
from Orion as the crew observes a solar eclipse from the moon. And this solar
eclipse is only visible to the crew on the spacecraft. It's not visible to
anybody on Earth. The science team is interested in several different targets
for them during this time frame. And we're personally looking forward to
getting those images as well. Again during the beginning portion of this
eclipse the astronauts will need to use eclipse glasses just like we do from
Earth to safely view it. Once the moon has completely covered the Sun they'll
be able to take off those glasses for almost an hour. Totality on Earth during
a solar eclipse lasts only a couple of minutes so this opportunity gives them a
chance to look out into deep space and to look into see if there are other
planets nearby. What you're seeing right now is the solar corona that's the outer
atmosphere of the Sun and the science team is very interested in any images
that the crew can capture of this. They're hoping that they'll take
pictures and describe the visibility color and shape of the solar corona as a
whole and its substructures those plumes and streamers.
see right out there the long lens you'll see again you're looking at a live view
from the Orion spacecraft on the Artemis to mission Orion is now two hundred and
fifty two thousand one hundred twenty five miles away from us all on earth
we're here in the Artemis mission control room in Houston Texas and what
you had just before we lost that view quickly was the corona of the Sun
peaking around the moon as the astronauts are entering a solar eclipse
for this portion of the lunar flyby. We're now over 5,500 statute miles from
the moon. That closest approach today was just about 4,067 statute miles away.
Teams in the room beginning to get a little busier and filter in and out as
we are stepping through a handover. The Orbit 1 team is handing over to Orbit 2
who will continue monitoring lunar flyby and all of the systems aboard the Orion spacecraft.
You're getting your last few views of the solar corona as the moon begins to take center stage
and completely cover the sun. If you see that bright dot up near the top left of your screen,
we think right now that that may be a part of the spacecraft, but we'll be sure to correct that if
we end up figuring out later that it is something else entirely.
It has been an absolute honor to join you here today for the Lunar Flyby of Artemis
2, the first time humans have flown by the Moon in over 50 years.
I'm Leah Cheshire-Mustachio, and I'm excited now to hand over the...
The game is shifting around in the windows, and we are transferring settings on a camera
to pick up Earth's shine.
know our rules that we don't talk when the crew is talking so wanted to give victor glover a moment
there to call down what he was seeing now that the moon is covering the sun a really amazing
time during today's lunar flyby again thank you so much for letting us help tell this story today
i am leah cheshire mustachio handing it over to my friend anna schneider at the pao console as the
orbit 2 team comes to join us so thank you so mucho and i hope you all enjoy tonight anna you
You can take it away.
Thank you so much, Leah.
And it's been a joy listening to your coverage over the last several hours.
So as you mentioned, the Orbit 2 team of flight controllers is currently making their way
on console and completing a shift handover with the Orbit 1 team of flight
controllers.
The Orbit 2
team tonight will be led by Flight Director Diane Daly.
And she is currently handing over with the Orbot 1 flight director there on your screen,
who was Flight Director Jeff Radigan.
The Artemis II crew currently onboard the Orion spacecraft.
It continues to observe the eclipse that they are witnessing.
There's about 43 minutes remaining in that eclipse period.
This is Artemis Mission Control.
You are currently seeing a live view of the solar ray wing cameras on the Orion spacecraft,
we spoke with our science team and they did determine that that dot in the distance is Venus.
This is Artemis Mission Control.
You were just hearing some communications called down from NASA astronaut Victor Glover currently
on board the Orion spacecraft.
They are currently observing an eclipse.
There's about 39 minutes remaining in that eclipse period.
Currently we are in a forward link LOS or loss of signal so the crew can communicate down.
So we are in a forward-link loss of signal.
We do expect to regain signal in about three minutes, and at that point,
then the ground can communicate back up to the crew onboard the Orion spacecraft.
In the meantime, the crew can continue to communicate down to the ground.
The ground is just unable to respond, so they are continuing
to provide some science observations during this eclipse period.
They've made some comments about Earthshine, which is the sunlight reflected
from Earth when they come around towards the moon's near side late in this fly-by window.
The glow around the moon is beginning to become a little bit more even.
It's not so much distinct just where the sun's set on the moon's horizon flying
through the trajectory and then the sun's going to come up out of the other side.
I think it's the glow around...
Integrity Houston, we have that SITREP loud and clear and we are back with you.
How do you hear me?
Copy.
Victor, we're handing you over to science for some critical questions.
Thanks for your report.
Integrity Science, we were loving your science at Reps in the Blind,
and it should come as no surprise that we have a number of follow-up questions.
First, you mentioned read-observing meteors.
Can you speak to that?
Were you referring to comets or impact flashes or something else?
Amazing news.
I literally just looked over at the CERN and they were jumping up and down literally.
If you could describe where on the moon you saw them, please.
South of the equator.
Incredible news, Reid.
And reminder, we have citizen scientists here on Earth looking for impact flashes.
So hearing you saw them on the near side means that people saw them too.
This is Artemis Mission Control.
We have regained that signal.
So the team here in Mission Control was able to call back up to the crew on board the Orion spacecraft
as they continue their lunar flyby.
Specifically, they are now in that eclipse period.
So the science team here in mission control was able to ask some questions
about some of the situational reports they were providing during that loss of signal.
Specifically, they were interested in some of the meteors that they mentioned seeing
and those impact flashes.
and they did provide confirmation that they did see at least four impact flashes during that last signal.
Are you still with us, Houston, or did we lose you?
Integrity, I hear you loud and clear. How do you hear me?
Okay, we hear you loud enough to hear me, but the entire moon, it's glowing behind the entire moon.
The entire moon, you still might go around the entire limb, just bumps as you go around it.
The glow around the moon, once your eyes adjust, is easily 10 times the diameters of the sun around the entire moon.
Incredible to hear, Jeremy.
Were you able to actually pick out any discrete features on the lunar surface?
And if so, how do they look different than when you observe them in solar illumination?
You know, the topography on the limb for the Earth's glow, we're about a quarter moon,
you know waxing quarter moon if you will from the earth globe perspective i'm just not able to tell
what i'm looking at yet in the earth glow understood thanks jeremy um one other question
for you on the solar corona were you actually able to see any structure or color in the corona
before uh the most of it disappeared behind the moon i saw one plume position of the sun that was
very short-lived when I could see the plume. Exactly what we were looking for. Thanks,
Jeremy. And a heads up that we calculated here on the ground about how long you could see the
corona for, and we expect it to start to appear again in the next 11 minutes. Thanks for those
amazing descriptions. Integrity Houston, we're following along as well. That was outstanding.
If you haven't already, just reminding you to swap positions at the windows.
And that brief LOS we had previously was due to a data rate change expected.
Integrity Science, one more request for you.
While it's still fresh in your mind, any annotations or sketches you want to make of what you're seeing either around the corona structures you just mentioned or even on Ershine would be so appreciated.
And if the annotations come in the next block where you're cleaning up your documentation,
that sounds like a good plan to me.
This is Artemis Mission Control.
On the bottom right corner of your screen, you can see a view of the Science Officer
console here in Mission Control.
And we've been hearing that communication between the Science Officer.
The Orbit 1 Science Officer is Kelsey Young, and she's been asking questions to the crew,
specifically CSA astronaut Jeremy Hansen, based on the observations they've been making during this eclipse period.
And then in the upper left-hand corner of your screen, you can see a view of the Artemis real-time orbit website,
which provides updates on the velocity and the distance from Earth and the moon of the Orion spacecraft
as it continues to make its way back to Earth.
The distance from the moon will continue to increase at this point.
So right now, Orion and its crew are about 6,300 miles away from the moon and about 251,000 miles away from
the Earth.
Great, SITREP Victor.
That sounds like a good config, and we're showing coronal effects start to appear on your video camera.
So in the next few minutes, we should start to hear your observations.
This is Artemis Mission Control.
We just heard the crew call down to the team here in Houston, reporting that they have swapped out who is in
the windows for the final portion of the lunar flyby so Christina Cook is in
window one with Jeremy Hansen in window two and Reid in window three. Reid is
focusing on observing Corona which is the solar corona which is the sun's
outermost atmosphere. There is about 18 minutes remaining in the eclipse period.
evolved to see what we're seeing. It is amazing.
Amazing. Thank you, Victor. Just one more logistics note. We have gone
We have turned the DU's all the way as dim as they can
go so there's no, you can't see anything on the screens.
We copy all. Excited for what you see next. Around the moon, but you know
right off the, well we're upside down now, but from upside down 4 o'clock
right off the edge of the moon, looks like to the left and something right off
off the land, it looks orange, as you said, we might see, we're seeing, and so in unreal
view, yeah, the moon in the foreground is one of the darkest things we see out the window,
and now it's deep space behind it is kind of dark blue, like it looks from Earth, but
we can also still see stars, it's a, quite a wicked view.
Victor, how long are we processing?
this is just absolutely beautiful and inspiring to hear and Victor we suspect what you're seeing
is Saturn and Mars that reddish object is likely Mars good opportunity to look to the future of
where we're going it's point the four o'clock on the earth shine side is definitely getting
brighter still no coronal structure Houston copies we aren't able to which Mars but we
We can clearly see Mare and the Earth shine.
We copy.
This is Artemis Mission Control in Houston, Texas.
We have not seen an impact flash in the last five minutes.
Sounds unlucky, but you had a pretty strong start, so we'll take it.
On the terminator, Regis, I want...
Amazing.
Integrity science, and as you look around our solar system neighborhood, you should
see Saturn setting behind the moon right now.
This is Artemis Mission Control in Houston, Texas.
We are currently five days, two hours and 44 minutes into the Artemis II mission and we have
about 11 minutes remaining in the eclipse at the latter half of the lunar flyby
that the Artemis 2 crew is experiencing onboard the Orion spacecraft.
We've received several different call downs from the crew and questions
up from the science officer here in Mission Control.
One of the things that they said that they were able to see is Mars off in the distance
and then the science team also confirmed
that they should be seeing Saturn setting behind the moon.
They've also acknowledged seeing several different impact flashes and these are flashes
of lights from meteorites striking the surface of the moon.
They've also mentioned the solar corona which is the sun's outermost atmosphere.
Here in Mission Control Houston, the Orbit 1
and Orbit 2 teams have officially completed their handover.
So the Orbit 2 team is now leading here in Mission Control and that is being led
by Flight Director Diane Daly and the CAPCOM here in Mission control will be Tess Caswell.
And you can see there on your screen on the right hand side is the Flight Director console
and Diane Daly is in the far right of that screen and Tess Caswall the CAPCOM
or capsule communicator is in the left hand of that screen.
We're growing intensity, 4 o'clock position on the...
Integrity Science, we copy and we're starting to see it on the vehicle stream.
I'm looking forward to any coronal observations you can share with us.
This is Artemis Mission Control.
That view you're seeing on your screen is coming from the solar array wing cameras outside
of the Orion spacecraft and you can see the light starting to come into view
as the solar eclipse period is starting to end integrity still no coronal structure and intensity
copy victor um and reminder um you should you still should have several minutes before the
eclipse classes need to go on um and we can send you up a reminder when you're getting close to
take your eyes away from the d5 viewfinder but you should be good for several more minutes
thank you and yes please send up the reminder thank you i believe the most popular term is
The light, it grows in intensity and you can still see Earth shine even though the sun's
brightness is definitely growing in intensity.
Love the description, Victor.
I'm sure as the next couple minutes progress, more of those structures will continue to
pop out.
This is Artemis Mission Control in Houston, Texas.
The Artemis II astronauts onboard the Orion spacecraft are currently observing an eclipse
And to the crew onboard the spacecraft, the eclipse looks much like a total solar eclipse here
on Earth, except the moon is much larger compared to the sun, unlike a terrestrial solar eclipse
where the moon and the sun appear the same size in the sky.
We are definitely starting to see structure.
That baby here is rapidly growing toward the night, almost as if it were reaching out for Venus
or for the Earth, top of the Luxor at night in Las Vegas.
this looks like what that wants to be when it grows up integrity science glad to hear you're
following your training of tell it like you see it slowly starting to widen pretty and integrity
houston great words reminder for you we are approaching the brightness level at which
you should no longer be using the viewfinder on the d5 the heads up this is artemis mish control
Oh, and I think we're seeing some directionality.
Some of it is going in different directions because it appears to be moving
and combining and recombining to be going, like, down toward the south pole of the moon,
but it's – and then coming back together.
Like, looking at a plane, light, and then there were, like, two streamers that were going –
Houston copies all.
It's starting to get a little warm.
And we copied all.
We wanted to remind you at this point on the eclipse glasses.
It should be about time for those.
Thanks for the report.
We sure wish we were there with you.
This is Artemis Mission Control.
The eclipse period is coming to an end and we did hear that call up that the crew now has
to put on those eclipse glasses to be able to protect their eyes
for this final portion of the eclipse and these views coming to you
from the solar array wing cameras on the Orion spacecraft.
Houston, if you could give me about 20 new superlatives in the mission summary for tomorrow,
that will help my vocab.
We will solicit input from the team.
This is Artemis Mission Control there on your screen.
You can see a live look inside of the CIR or the Science Evaluation Room here
in Mission Control Houston just down the hallway from the Artemis Flight Control Room.
Integrity, Houston, back with you after a data rate change.
Regarding the SAW III camera T, low caution, no action for you.
It just got a little cool during the eclipse.
We copied it fantastically.
And Integrity Science, this is basically wrapping up your fly-by-day observations.
I can't say enough how much science we've already learned
and how much inspiration you've provided to our entire team,
the lunar science community, and the entire world with what you were able to bring today.
You really brought the moon closer for us today,
and we cannot say thank you enough.
And science signing off and can't wait to talk to you tomorrow morning.
Beautiful words, Reed.
Thanks so much.
And this is Artemis Mission Control.
The Lunar Flyby Observation Period is starting to come to a close following that eclipse.
And there on your screen you can see a look into the Science Evaluation Room or the SUR
which is embedded within Mission Control to provide science input.
And they provided that input throughout the live flyby operations today.
They also have a back room called the science mission operations room
that processes data, evaluates imagery, and supports rapid analysis.
And then of course we have the science officer on console here in the Artemis flight control room,
which you can see a view there on the bottom right-hand corner of your screen.
The science officer throughout the flyby operations
today has been Kelsey Young, who is the Artemis science flight operations lead.
And then to her left is Angela Garcia, who will be the science officer taking over for Orbit 2.
And for the past seven hours or so, the crew has been going
through their lunar flyby observation period, and now they will wrap up that period
and complete some final tasks and begin downlinking some of the amazing imagery
that they've captured throughout the day, as well as some of the observations
that they've recorded and now on your screen you're seeing a live look from the orion spacecraft
from those solar ray wing cameras the solar eclipse period ended just a few minutes ago
and during this eclipse towards the end of the flyby window it lasted about an hour and it was
when the sun was hidden from view behind the opposite side of the moon from the perspective
of the orion space craft and its crew and during that time the crew saw a mostly dark moon and they
They used the opportunity to analyze the solar corona, which is the sun's outermost atmosphere
while it was visible.
And then once the sun was completely out of view behind the moon, the crew looked for
impact flashes, which they reported seeing multiple impact flashes, and those are flashes
of light from meteoroids striking the surface of the moon.
They also looked for dusts lofting above the limb or the edge of the moon, along with some
deep space targets, including planets.
They noticed Mars off to the distance and we also saw Venus on one
of the solar ray wing cameras early on in the eclipse period.
The crew also looked at parts of the moon illuminated by earth shine,
which is the sunlight reflected from the earth when they come
around toward the moon's near side at the very end of that fly-by window.
Integrity Houston, understand that you are still reflecting upon
and consolidating your lunar observations.
At your convenience, I have two items related to the upcoming VIP event.
All right, first we wanted to let you know that the message
for that upcoming event is on board for review at your convenience.
That's message 3.06.04.
The second item is that we've seen a couple of video blips in previous events.
So during the HDPAO setup activity, we're wondering if Jeremy could please confirm
us that the TS rate is set to 1300 when you get to step 10. We copy Jeremy thanks
and for the record the phenomenal Jenny has gone on to her next appointment of
the day and you've now got TESS with you. No worries happy to be here. This is
Artemis Mission Control we heard some communication there between the CAPCOM
or capsule communicator here in Mission Control which for orbit 2 is TESS
Caswell and the CSA or Canadian Space Agency astronaut on board the Orion
spacecraft Jeremy Hansen they were discussing an upcoming public affairs
event and integrity three-minute warning for the maneuver back to bias tail to
Sun the crew on board the Orion spacecraft recently completed their
lunar observation period it was an approximately seven hour period of time
in which they were focused on several different targets identified by the
science team here on the ground that they studied and prepared for ahead of
time and then they also were referencing a lunar targeting package that was uplinked
about a day ago with those final targets now they are completing some post lunar flyby activities
so they're working to clean up their observations that they've made and also working to downlink
some of the photos that they've taken throughout the day the science team here on the ground will
then work to get as much data as they can overnight and then there will be a post flyby
conference tomorrow after the crew wakes up and that's not a debrief but a
science data collection to capture their nuanced experience while they're still
in the field and the experience is still fresh and then of course there will also
be a public affairs downlink event later in the day now that the post once the
post lunar flyby activities are complete and then after that the crew will go
into some of their final activities for the day they will have a private medical
conference or PMC with the medical teams here on the ground. These are regular conferences that
they have at the end of every day and then there's also a flight director conference that they will
have before they go into their pre-sleep period during which they can complete hygiene activities
and they will have the chance to eat their dinner and complete any other final personal activities
for the day before they head into their sleep period. Checking and integrity a firm we are go
to start the stream okay Houston the stream is started we copy good settings
and we've got a good view sorry for the delay Jeremy we were talking that a bit
but it was a bit broken so please repeat for us integrity Houston we like the
scene at your convenience we'll take a 10 count with Jeremy in frame great
voice check and good words we like the scene and integrity Houston we are
We are seeing a black cable going right through the middle of the scene.
At your convenience, if you would please move that, PAO would appreciate it.
This is Artemis Mission Control.
We're currently five days, three hours, and 21 minutes into the Artemis II mission
following a liftoff from NASA's Kennedy Space Center in Florida on Wednesday, April 1st.
The crew onboard the Orion spacecraft is currently wrapping up their lunar flyby cleanup activities.
And NASA astronaut Christina Cook there calling down to the ground regarding some public affairs
imagery that was captured during the lunar flyby activities to reference to PCD.
That is in reference to their portable computing devices, which are basically tablets that
they're able to transfer files and also follow along on processes and procedures and their
timelines for the day. This is Artemis Mission Control in Houston, Texas.
Currently on console here in Mission Control is the Orbit 2 team of flight
controllers being led by flight director Diane Daly and the CAPCOM or capsule
communicator who serves as the single voice link up to the crew is Tess
Caswell. The crew onboard the Orion spacecraft recently wrapped up their
lunar flyby observation period and now they are completing some cleanup
activities and transferring some data and files down to the ground following that lunar flyby.
Many of these files will be analyzed by the science team overnight in advance of a
post lunar flyby conference tomorrow once the crew wakes up.
The crew is also preparing for an upcoming public affairs downlink event
and then following that downlink they will have a few final activities for the day including a
private medical conference with their team here on the ground. These are
standard conferences that happen at the end of every day and they'll also have a
private conference with the flight director here in Mission Control to go
over the vehicle status and any other questions or concerns they may have for
the remainder of their flight. We are currently in flight day six and we have
a splashdown expected on Friday April 10th. That splashdown expected in about
three days, 21 hours, and 49 minutes from now.
During the lunar flyby, and as part of Artemis II, it marked the first time in more than
50 years that humans were able to observe the moon directly and provided a critical
opportunity to practice how lunar science will be conducted during future Artemis missions.
The moon preserves a near-continuous record of solar system history that has been erased
on Earth, and with no atmosphere, weather,
or plate tectonics, the lunar surface retains evidence
of ancient impacts, volcanism, and solar activity
that scientists can study today.
Studying the moon helps scientists understand how
planets formed and evolved,
how the moon influenced Earth's history,
and how the early sun shaped conditions
across the inner solar system.
The moon also serves as a unique platform
for studying the broader universe.
The science on Artemis is designed
around questions best answered by humans working alongside robotic systems combining decades
of robotic lunar data with real-time human judgment, context and adaptability.
Currently on your screen you're seeing a look at the Artemis real-time orbit website.
You can access this website at any time throughout the mission at nasa.gov slash track Artemis.
It provides updates on the velocity as well as the distance from Earth and the distance
from the moon of the Orion spacecraft and its crew.
The crew currently onboard the Orion spacecraft includes NASA astronaut Reid Wiseman
who is the commander for the mission, NASA astronaut Victor Glover who is the pilot,
alongside the two mission specialists who are Christina Cooke and Jeremy Hansen
of the Canadian Space Agency.
Currently the Orion spacecraft is about 250,000 miles away from the Earth
And that distance now will continue to close down ahead of that splashdown on April 10th.
And they are now about 8,100 miles away from the moon and that distance will continue
to increase as they are now in the return leg of their journey.
Go ahead Integrity.
We will put that in work.
Great to be talking to you too.
This is Artemis Mission Control in Houston, Texas.
We're currently five days, three hours and 37 minutes into the Artemis II mission.
The crew onboard the Orion spacecraft has recently concluded their lunar observation period
during the lunar flyby.
As part of that lunar flyby, the Orion spacecraft
and its crew made the closest approach to the moon at a distance of 4,067 miles away
from the surface at approximately 6 p.m. central time, 7 p.m., eastern time.
Now, although the Artemis II mission is a new opportunity to study the moon,
teams are also conducting other scientific experiments, including on the crew themselves.
Here's a little bit more about the science of the mission.
Artemis II is our return of humans to the moon, flying around the moon on board Orion.
But along with that, we're doing a lot of great science.
One of the exciting things about the Artemis missions to the moon is that science is actually a fundamental pillar of why we explore.
why we're going what we're doing in artemis i think it's incredibly exciting that not only
are we testing the vehicle but we're testing science on board science where the astronauts
are conducting experiments science writing along with the astronauts we have astronauts
looking outside the window and really observing the lunar surface it will help us understand the
deep space environment it will help u s understand how that environment affects our astronauts our
systems and life in general. So deep space is a challenge for us because you
have to leave Earth's protective magnetic field. Here in low-earth orbit
the crew members are protected from some of the harmful radiation. Going to the
moon they'll no longer be protected so they'll have a higher radiation exposure.
Much like Artemis 1 we have so many radiation sensors and detectors that are
inside the capsule so that we can fully understand and appreciate the radiation
environment for protecting our astronauts. In my hand here I'm holding a
tissue chip model this is the exact design that it's going to be flying
alongside the astronauts. We'll be collecting samples from each of the crew
members and we can make these organ chips out of the astronauts themselves.
So every crew member will have their own avatar on board and then upon return we
can evaluate that deep space radiation environment and what that compares to
the astronaut themselves. Not only are they going to help change the course of
medicine for the astronauts, but revolutionizing that on Earth as well.
We're looking at sleep, we're looking at team dynamics, we're
looking at how you interact with the environment. We're also looking at the
immune system, so what are the biomarkers? We're using saliva as a method to study
hormones and different things in your body that may change during a mission
like this. And then finally, how do we function after microgravity, you know,
being close to the moon then returning to earth which will ultimately help us achieve our goal
of getting humans to mars and then on top of that we have an opportunity to look at the moon
from deep space on the far side for the first time in over 50 years
having human eyeballs and brains back around the moon is going to unlock a new generation
of lunar science discovery the human eyeball is capable of taking in so much data in just
a split second they'll be able to tackle impact history volcanic history they'll be
able to look at how the albedo or kind of the the shade and hue of the moon and the color of
the moon can tell us something about how that terrain evolved over time we're integrating
science in ways that have never been integrated into human exploration before we have a front room
mission control flight controller position called the science officer we have a brand new science
back room where it's basically our brain trust of lunar scientists and geologists supporting
the crews of the future, and Artemis II will allow us to really test how this works so
that future missions are really set up for success.
We'll also be deploying some CubeSats, they're small shoebox-sized spacecraft of their own.
They're each provided by another country, one of our partners.
As they conduct their research, they'll complement what we are doing at the Moon with Orion.
It is so incredibly exciting to be a part of this mission.
It has been, you know, really one of the privileges of a lifetime.
I can see the work I'm doing benefit crew members right now and benefit the crew members
in the future.
So it's incredibly exciting and it's very rewarding.
As this rocket launches humanity off of the Earth, we'll be setting the stage through
our science to prepare humanity to leave Earth and explore the solar system.
And as part of that, we are going to inhibit cabin leak detection.
The edge key manual response is still available.
Copy thumbs up.
This is Artemis Mission Control.
Again, we're hearing some communication between the ground here
and the Artemis flight control room in Houston, Texas, specifically the CAPCOM
or capsule communicator, who for orbit two is Tess Caswell and the crew
on board the Orion spacecraft, that spacecraft named Integrity by its crew.
They are preparing for an upcoming public affairs event,
so they are discussing the camera views, which we will see here shortly.
There on your screen on the left-hand side, you can see the Artemis real-time orbit website
or aero.
The Artemis real-time orbit website there
on the left-hand side of your screen provides updates
on the velocity of the Orion spacecraft during its journey
around the moon following a lunar flyby earlier today
which concluded about an hour ago.
The crew has been conducting some cleanup tasks
so they've been transferring some of their documentation,
their photos and data that they captured during the flyby
to the ground to be evaluated by the science team and, of course,
Some of that imagery will also be evaluated by the public affairs team here at NASA
and then shared with the world once it's available.
The crew will also have a post-lunar fly-by conference with the science team tomorrow
following their sleep period to go over some of their observations
while it's still fresh and at the top of their mind.
On the bottom right-hand corner of your screen,
you can see a look into the Artemis Flight Control Room here in Mission Control Houston,
specifically the Flight Director Consul and the CAPCOM or Capsule Communicator Consul.
The Flight Director currently on Consul for Orbit 2 is Diane Daly.
And throughout the Artemis 2 mission there are three shifts or orbits of flight controllers
who provide 24-7 coverage and support to the Artemis II crew and the Orion spacecraft
and its systems during its journey around the moon.
We are expecting a splashdown on Friday, April 10th.
That splashdown will take place in about three days, 21 hours and 33 minutes.
During the lunar flyby that took place earlier today, Orion, again that spacecraft named
Integrity by its crew, passed approximately 4,000 to 6,000 miles from the moon
and provided the crew with a full disc view of the lunar surface.
And from that higher vantage point, much farther than Apollo's lunar orbits on average,
The astronauts were able to observe both poles and large scale geological features in a single view.
And there on your screen you're currently seeing a live look inside the cabin of the Orion spacecraft.
Integrity Houston, we are three minutes out from an on time start and we have adjusted the fan speed.
We'll take a thumbs up if you're happy with it.
Copy thumbs up.
Pirlative thumbs up.
And there on your screen you can see all
of the Artemis II crew members, CSA astronaut Jeremy Hansen just floated
out of view behind the camera, but you can still see NASA astronaut Reid Wiseman,
NASA astronaut Christina Cook, and NASA astronaut Victor Glover as they prepare
for an upcoming public affairs downlink event which is scheduled
to take place in just a couple minutes from now.
And there floating back onto the screen is CSA
or Canadian Space Agency astronaut Jeremy Hanson.
He is making himself comfy on some of the AUX or Orion Crew Survival System suits that have been stowed for the outbound and now return journey.
Shortly after the completion of these couple of public affairs downlink events, the crew will begin winding down for their day and they will have the opportunity to eat dinner.
Some of the items on their menu today for dinner include chicken with corn and black beans, sweet and sour pork, rice pilaf, spicy green beans, citrus fruit salad, and maple cream cookies.
And now we will go ahead and stand by for the public affairs event beginning in just about a minute.
Integrity, Houston, no action for the DU1 caution. We're taking a look.
Integrity, this is Houston. Are you ready for the event?
Ready for the event.
Hello, Houston. Integrity is ready for the event
Administrator Isaacman, this is Mission Control Houston. Please call Integrity for a voice check
Integrity, Jared Isaacman, comm check
Administrator Isaacmen, we've got you loud and clear, Sir. How us?
I've got you louder and clearer
Artemis II crew, we have a very special guest who wanted to be the first person to greet you after your return from the far side of the moon
Reid, Victor, Christina, and Jeremy, it's my honor to introduce the President of the
United States of America, President Donald J. Trump.
Over to you, sir.
PRESIDENT DONALD J. Well, thank you very much, Jared, and you are doing a fantastic
job.
And hello, very special hello to Artemis II.
Today you've made history and made all America really proud, incredibly proud.
We have a lot of things to be proud of lately, but this is – there's nothing like what
you're doing circling around the moon for the first time in more than a half a century
and breaking the all-time record for the farthest distance from planet Earth. Humans have really
never seen anything quite like what you're doing in a manned spacecraft. It's really
special. I want to personally salute and congratulate Commander Reid Weissman, Pilot Victor Glover,
Specialist Christina Koch and Jeremy Hansen and I also want to thank the
entire amazing team at NASA headed by Jared is a very special guy by the way
and you all made this day possible and you've really inspired the entire world
really everybody's watching I find it incredible I just watch you go to the
back of the moon and people haven't been there in a long time we can say but it's
It's going to be more and more prevalent because we're going to be doing a lot of traveling.
And then you're going to ultimately do the whole big trip to Mars, and that's going to
be very exciting.
So you look at — we had no astronaut has been to the moon since the days of Apollo
program.
The Apollo program was also very special, but that was 50 years ago.
And at long last, America is back, and America is back in many ways stronger than ever before
with the hottest country anywhere in the world.
The Artemis crew flew in the most powerful rocket NASA
has ever made, ever launched,
traveled over a quarter of a million miles,
broke the distance record set by the legendary Apollo 13.
And America is a frontier nation,
and the four brave astronauts of Artemis II
are a modern-day, you really are modern-day pioneers,
all of you, and one of them happens to be a neighbor.
You know who that is, right?
You have a special person over there, a neighbor,
and we like our neighbor.
Your mission paves the way for America's return
to the lunar surface very soon.
We're going all out.
We're doing everything we can, and it's headed up by Jared.
We'll plant our flag once again,
and this time we won't just leave footprints.
We'll establish a permanent presence on the moon,
and we'll push on to Mars.
That'll be very exciting.
I'm waiting for that so much.
I'd love to be here, but maybe we won't quite make it in terms of timing.
But we will be up in the moon, and that's going to happen soon.
So America will be second to none in space and everything else that we're doing.
And we will continue to lead the whole thing into the stars, this incredible journey into the stars.
So I just wanted an honor to speak to you, and I wanted to congratulate each and every one of you.
and tell me what is the most unforgettable part of this really historic day the whole world is
watching and listening please tell me president this call is certainly special to all of us and
we really have a lot of faith in our administrator jared isaacman who is with you we appreciate his
leadership in nasa and in the international community we are doing great things and we
are proud to be a part of i have to tell you uh as we came around uh the near side of the moon
seeing all the sights that we've seen from earth for all of our lives but we're seeing them from
a different perspective and then we started to get a glimpse of the and we saw sites oriental
uh sites that no human has ever seen before not even in apollo and that was amazing for us
and then the surprise of the day we just came out of an eclipse where the sun moon and the
entire dark moon about that big right out the window that we were watching we could see the
the corona of the sun, and then we could see the planet train line up at Mars, and all
of us commented how excited we are to watch this nation and this planet become a two-planet
species.
That is fantastic.
You know, I had a decision to make in my first term, and the decision is, what are we going
to do at NASA?
Are we going to have it be revived, or are we going to close it down?
And I had very little hesitation, and it's really great to have somebody like Jared involved,
because he really makes it much easier for me.
But it was not even a question in my own mind.
We just — we've spent what we had to do.
And then, of course, we have Space Force.
And Space Force is very much related to what you're doing.
And that was my baby. That was a very important one.
And it's turning out —
it'll turn out to be truly one of the most important,
I believe, decisions I've ever made.
So we're very proud of Space Force,
and we're very of all of you.
Does anybody else have anything to say?
lot of people listening mr. president to be here with you speaking about our
incredible day today I think one of the biggest highlights was coming back from
the far side of the moon and having the first glimpses of planet Earth again
after being out of communication for about 45 minutes it really just reminds
you what a special place we have and how important it is for our nation to word
to lead and not follow in exploring deep space I'd like to ask what was your
feeling when you had no communication, zero communication, all of a sudden it was cut off by
obviously your very special location. What was your feeling when you
had no communication? A little bit different, perhaps.
Yes, Mr. President, it was. I said a little prayer, but then I had to keep rolling.
I was actually recording scientific observations of the far side of the moon.
You know, that is actually the time when we were the farthest and the closest to the moon.
And so we were really able to make some of our most detailed observations of the far side of the moon up close.
And so we Were busy up here working really hard.
And I must say, it was actually quite nice.
Did you see a difference, a big difference, between the far side
of the moon and the near side of the Moon?
Was there a difference in feel or a difference in look?
What did you see?
Well, Mr. President, we certainly did.
And our science team really set us up well to understand what they thought we might see.
and the gravitational pull of the Earth has had a profound effect on the near side of the moon,
changing all those dark maoris, those dark patches of the moon you see from Earth.
It's very different on the far side.
While you see some small patches of those maori in deep craters,
it's very much absent on that side, so that's really neat.
And while I have the microphone, sir, I just want to thank you on behalf of Canada.
The space leadership you spoke of from America truly is extraordinary.
I've said this many times before, a nation that leads like that and creates and sets
big goals for humanity that brings other countries along with it is truly incredible.
And I know that's a very intentional, not a necessary decision, intentional decision
to lead by example and to allow other countries like Canada to share our gifts and help you
achieve these mutually beneficial goals like establishing a presence on the moon and eventually
going to Mars.
And Canadians are so proud to be a part of this program.
THE PRESIDENT Well, I have to say I spoke to a very special person, Wayne Gretzky, who
I think you know, the great one.
And I spoke to your prime minister and many other friends I have in Canada.
They are so proud of you.
And you have a lot of courage.
I'm not sure if they'd want to do that.
I'm not even sure if the great one would want to do, to be honest with you.
But you have a of courage doing what you're doing, a lot of bravery and a lot of – a
A lot of genius, but they're very, very proud of you.
Administrator, I was going to just get a quick comm check,
make sure you guys are still on the line and we didn't have a handover.
I am. Yes, I am.
And back over to you, Mr. President.
Yeah, I think we might have gotten cut off.
It is a long distance. It's a long ways.
The reception's been great.
There's a little bit of about a nine-second delay,
But, no, I just had a statement for—I don't know what you heard, but I was just saying they're very proud of your brilliant person from Canada on the ship.
And Wayne Gretzky is a great friend of mine, and he's very proud of him.
And the prime minister I spoke to, they're very, very honored that you have a courageous person from Canada.
You have a lot of courageous people from Canada.
So it was very nice.
I'm not sure if you heard me say that, but it was very Nice.
Yes, Mr. President, we heard that, and we do love our Jeremy Hansen.
We love all our Canadian astronauts, Jenny Gibbons, Josh Kutryk.
They're just great people, and they're such a welcome addition to our Corps.
Great. Well, I really look forward to, when we can, I look forward to seeing you in the Oval Office.
I'll ask Jared to bring you over, and I'll ask for your autograph,
because I don't really ask for autographs much, but you deserve that.
you really are something. Everybody's talking about this. And I look forward to having you in
the Oval Office at the White House, and we will celebrate your incredible achievements and
triumphs. This is big. This is really big stuff. The whole world is talking about it. And if you
have the time, I will certainly find the time. I've been pretty busy also, as you know, but I
will absolutely find the time, and we'll get together. And I'm going to be giving you a big
salute on behalf of the American people and beyond that thank you for that mr.
president and when you want us we will be there and thank you for your
leadership thank you to Jared for his leadership really thank you for taking
the time out today to visit NASA it's really special for us but it's really
special for the team on the ground a whole team of people all around the
world pulled this off and we just want to say thank you to all of you for this
it is the thrill and honor of a lifetime to have been on this journey today was
amazing. But this three-year journey has been amazing, and it was made people, made possible
by the American people and the Canadian people. And we're so grateful to you all. Thank you very
much. Well, thank you very much. And Jared, congratulations. We'll see you soon. And I know
that you have Mars very much in your mind, so we'll start thinking about that pretty soon, I think. And
thank you. Congratulations to everybody. I'll see you at the Oval Office.
Thank you for your time, Mr. President. It's been an honor.
Thank you very much. Bye.
Integrity, this is Houston ACR. That concludes the event. Thank you.
Thank you to all participants.
Integrity, we are now resuming operational audio communications.
Integrity, Houston, great job on the event.
Just a heads up, we are on track to start the next event on time at 4.15.
This is Artemis Mission Control in Houston, Texas.
We just had that public affairs event with President Donald Trump.
and the crew onboard the Orion spacecraft.
And coming up in about 10 minutes there will be another public affairs event,
that event taking place at a mission elapsed time of 5 days, 4 hours and 15 minutes.
Currently on your screen you're seeing a look at the Artemis real-time orbit website
which provides updates on the velocity as well as the distance
of the Orion spacecraft from both Earth and the moon.
The Orion spacecraft and its crew, that crew including Reid Wiseman, Victor Glover,
Christina Cooke and Jeremy Hansen are currently about 250,000 miles away from the Earth
and that distance is starting to become smaller as they are now on the return leg of their journey.
And they are about 9,300 miles away from moon.
They made their close approach to the moon.
Integrity Houston with a question about fan speed.
Hey Reid, we were wondering if this adjusted fan speed is something that you would like to keep going forward or if it was just a specific change request for the events this evening?
And Reid, we are able to support keeping the fan speed in this config. Happy to keep it here to collect data. We copy and we love seeing those smiles.
That's a good config. And while I've got you, we are three minutes out from an on-time start of the next event.
This is Artemis Mission Control in Houston, Texas.
You can see a live look of the Artemis II crew inside the Orion spacecraft cabin
as they prepare for another public affairs downlink event.
There on your screen is CSA astronaut Jeremy Hansen along
with NASA astronaut Reid Wiseman and NASA astronaut Victor Glover popping up.
Earlier today the crew completed their lunar flyby observation period during
which the Orion spacecraft and its crew passed approximately 4,000 to 6,000 miles
from the moon and provided the astronauts with a full disk view of the lunar surface.
And from that higher vantage point the astronauts were able to observe both poles
and large scale geological features in a single view.
Towards the tail end of that observation period they also were able to see an eclipse
and that eclipse period lasted about an hour and was when the sun was hidden
from view behind the opposite side of the moon from the perspective of Orion.
Since then, the crew has been working to clean up some of their observations and transfer some
of the data and imagery down to the ground to begin processing.
And the science team will take a look at that imagery as it comes down ahead
of a post lunar flyby conference tomorrow with the crew following their sleep period.
Now we are standing by for a second public affairs event taking place in about a minute.
Integrity, this is Houston.
Are you ready for the event?
Houston, Integrity is ready for the even.
administrator isaacman this is mission control houston please call integrity for a voice check
integrity jared isaacson com check administrator isaakman we've got you loud and clear up here
i've got you loudly clear and uh let's see if we can top that last uh po event that was pretty
special so we are going to uh spend the next 20 minutes doing q a from uh a number of questions
that have been submitted and we are going to start with one from me you uh you all have spent years
preparing for this moment and imagining what it must be like when you look down at the moon
at the lunar surface what has surprised you all that you did not anticipate
administrator great to chat with you uh just something that just shocked me because
and really using imagery and just the three-dimensionality of it.
You know from your experience of seeing the Earth from space
how it just seems different, and you look out in depth of things.
And when we were on the far side of the moon looking back at Earth,
it was just so obvious you had this sphere out in front of you of the moon
and this three-dimensional.
You really felt like you weren't in a capsule.
You'd been transported to the far sideof the moon,
and it really just bent your mind.
it was an extraordinary human experience i'm so grateful for it integrity uh jared anyone else
want to answer that one you know we had an amazing launch uh the sls is quite a powerful rocket and
got us into a 1200 by uh you know eventually a 100 mile orbit and
clearly powered speed and then we did our translunar injection and we were going quite
fast and so with all of that speed though it still took us days to get here and so the scope
of all of the things to a 321 foot tall rocket was amazing it just puts the you know the the
power required to do this in perspective but then even with all that power and to to get to those
velocities it still took us days hope that and the breadth of the distance we had to cover watching
the distance from earth count up and the distance from the moon countdown was one of the most
surprising things i've enjoyed well as i was trying to formulate an answer at first i could
anything because there are so many things to choose from I'll try to just
narrow it down but I'm gonna go with something we did yesterday a manual
flight test objective where we just basically got to sit at the vehicle it
was Jeremy and I this time and just drive drive around using the rotational
hand controller basically just drive it with the stick and how well it handled
how tight the control algorithms were, and watching it respond
when we actually degraded it on purpose by going into three degrees of freedom control,
by actually inhibiting some of the jets, which even though we have jet redundancy, of course,
for each other in these complicated algorithms.
So it was just amazing to be in a deep space spacecraft and just be flying it around by hand.
The one other thing I'll say how fast it has gone by, I'm not ready to go home.
This is, I can't believe that something this cramped
of quarters can fly by and still be fun every single minute.
And I'll just close out with, I think just scale, Jared,
is the thing that is just blowing my mind.
You know, you flew Polaris Dawn to some amazing apogee numbers
and on the International Space Station we're 250 nautical miles
up and that's the most beautiful view I think a human could
ever experience and we are dealing with numbers that are 250 000 miles and every time mission
control points this vehicle either at the moon or at earth way and it reminds me every day that
humans have to go we've got to explore we got to go further to expand our knowledge expand our
horizons and every time we take another step forward it makes the world seem a little bit
smaller and a little bit more manageable and just putting these numbers in perspective it
It is impossible as a human to look at these displays and comprehend them, but here we
are.
And NASA is doing this.
An international team is doing this, and they're doing it very well.
Excellent words, Integrity.
So certainly a very wild insertion orbit.
I can imagine the contrast between perigee and apogee, the scale of it all, the 3-D seeing
the moon come alive, and then certainly manual control, while every Dragon crew for the last
five years is very jealous on that.
Okay, so we're going to questions here.
This one, you, the Artemis II crew, inspire all of us, but what inspires you?
I think as you get older, your answer to that question changes a lot.
when I was a young boy and a young man just dancing an airplane flying overhead to me that
really lit a fire in me and then I think when you you reach your middle age it's just it is
interesting to watch leadership throughout the world kind of change the course of human
you can watch that unfold and now now that I'm I'm just a little bit over 50 you'll be there soon
now that I'M JUST A LITTLE BIT OVER 50 I MEAN IT ALL TIES BACK TO JUST FAMILY AND YOU YOU
understand just how much you the people that you surround yourself with and that is really uh every
every night when you go to bed that's really what you end up thinking at least that's what i end up
thinking thank you all right so uh here's a question it's a good one so for the artemis
three crew what is the first uh what is the advice you would pass along for the next astronauts that
will go in orion that's a great question jared we've actually been thinking about the artemise
two sorry the Artemis three crew since we were assigned as the Artemis two crew it was a big
the beginning of how we came up with how we wanted to fly this mission how we wanted
to buy down risk for the program and values as a crew and so uh you know over the over the course
of these three years we've taken a lot of notes so we've almost got a book to hand them but I think
a few practical things you're just sitting here we've been living for the past six days uh how
you pack is a huge impact to how you will live on the journey and so things like food and your
hygiene products and then you know yeah you've you know what's going on with our waste management
system the technology that we have practicing that and being familiar with that and being
being prepared mentally I used it on the space station I used it at home in training but I'll
be honest I wasn't really prepared to have to use it for over half the mission and but you know we
adapt and overcome and so I can't wait to talk to that crew I'm glad you said
it or else I was we we definitely have to fix some of the plumbing okay this
question is from Merriam-Webster so wordy one here so you are going to be
well you've already surpassed more than 250,000 miles from Earth farther than
any human has gone before so what are some words that come to mind when you
try to wrap your mind around this very unique experience.
I'll be honest with you.
The main word, because superlatives just don't do it justice, is humility.
We would never be here if it weren't for so many people that came before us, starting
with Neil Armstrong, Katherine Johnson, Dorothy Vaughan, civil rights movement leaders, everyone
who worked on this spacecraft.
Before we got here in our three years of training, we went all over the country and even to our
European and Canadian partners to see the people who have put their hands on this hardware,
the millions of parts from every valve to this entire thing, the people that put on
harnesses every day to rig it up in the VAB.
They all passed the record.
We definitely didn't pass the record up here alone.
So this is actually very similar to the question the President of the United States asked just
a brief bit ago.
But during the quiet moments on your journey, when you were out of contact with everyone
here on Earth, what were some of the thoughts that tended to occupy your mind most?
Yeah, as Victor said earlier, when we were on the far side of the moon and out of contact
with planet Earth, we all knew it, and it was a milestone.
We saw Earth disappear, the Earth set, but we were so busy with the science, and we have
such faith in our vehicle integrity, such faith in mission control, that we were just
at complete peace and just doing our job, and just trying to do a good job to collect
as much science data as we could while we were on the far side of the moon, and we were
just giddy in here, like of our lives.
being a bit humble but as soon as we went out of com with planet earth we did have maple cookies
as we just gathered together for about 30 seconds each one of us had a maple cream cookie and then
right back into the science but we had to take a moment to honor to honor that time going behind
earth and it was a very or i'm sorry going behind the moon and out of touch with earth and that was
a very surreal moment for this crew copy that copy good maple cookies on the far side and
And how has this journey changed—how has this journey already changed the way you see
our home planet and humanity's future among the stars?
There are so many directions I think we could go with that.
And I just, you know, I think that there's, you know—but I think real impact is local.
And to see the earth as an entire thing and look out at this system and to see it all in once.
But my daughters and just the, you know, the things that we can impact directly, the people that I can touch, that I can speak to, hug and show love and gratitude toward is the thing that I think is going to change and last.
And you also talked about the future that we're going to have in the stars.
And, you know, this mission, I think we swung for the fence and launched on our first try after learning a lot earlier this year.
But I think it set the stage for us to go out and continue to swing for the fence.
Hard in our Orion SLS and ground systems programs to go and get the next one teed up so that that crew can knock it off out of the park.
And so I have huge expectations for what's coming next.
Good words.
Are you feeling homesick for Earth?
I will tell you, last thing that comes to my eyes, I did start thinking about getting home.
It's not homesickness at all, but the first time, probably in three years,
I let my mind get past the moon and back towards home, and I had to catch myself right there.
You're an operator just like we are, and you know that is the place to be when you're up here.
We've got to look one step ahead.
What's next?
What's our next burn?
how are we setting up our trajectory to get home and we are going to do that we are locked in and
we are definitely excited for the second half of this mission and we we are on guard we are
first crew to fly this vehicle we are ready for any contingency in any scenario and we are
going to stay locked in every second until we are back on that navy ship and then home reunited with
our families and copy that astronauts like being in space that checks out um okay there's uh a lot
of questions from the space photography community how are the pictures going so far well um we all
love getting our hands on cameras and our eyes behind the lens here because we're just trying
to share the incredible things that we're seeing and that's obviously the the best way we can try
to do that i've been into night sky photography for a long time and so the dream come true for me
I have thought specifically to that community, the time lapses I've been trying to get,
those are a little tougher because we have a very dynamic vehicle.
It's not like being on ISS where you can get the city lights below and the auroras
and the spinning stars around the North Star.
There's a lot going on.
So, but what we got matter is out of this world.
When we viewed that eclipse, that was the one time we all said,
we literally cannot capture this with a camera.
Everything else, I think we've been able to, we've really put our hearts and minds
into making sure we understand so that we can bring that home to everyone.
But having to set the low light features for earth shine
on the moon while it's an eclipse, that's was a new one.
I had to dig deep in my book for that one.
And thanks for the iPhones, they've been working great.
Very glad to hear that.
And there are a couple billion people back here on Earth that are extremely excited to
look at the imagery you've captured up there.
Okay, well, I want to thank you all, Integrity, so Reid, Victor, Christina, Jeremy, on behalf
of NASA and space-loving people across the world, thank you for taking us with you to
moon. Thank you for your courage, all of your beautiful words that we've heard. You represent
the absolute best of us. We are proud of you, and we look forward to welcoming you back
safely to the good earth very soon. Godspeed, and go Artemis II.
Thank you so much, Administrator. We are just proud to be a part of this team, doing our
work every day and we are supported by a huge world of humans and we are just
honored to be a part of that thank you we'll see you soon
integrity this is Houston ACR that concludes the event thank you thank you
to all participants integrity we are now resuming operational audio comm